one of the hottest new ideas in fashion
comes from fungus yes fungus we're
talking about leather that's made from
mushrooms what this all-natural
plant-based alternative has none of the
environmental or cruelty concerns that
you have with animal skins lilia luciano
one of the best tv names in the business
visited a lab outside san francisco
where this mushroom leather is growing
and making an impact on fashion and
beyond
out west where cattle ranches have long
held sway
cowhide leather may be losing its luster
you can't grow a cow
to spec yeah
cows just do what they do yeah so that
is what was remarkable about natural
material that you can grow to form but
this material is made from mushrooms
under the watchful eyes of bay area
technicians definitely feels like
leather bolt threads is one company
engineering mushroom leather through
mycelium the underground network of
fibers that is the basis of mushrooms
from lululemon to stella mccartney and
adidas the company is turning heads with
what their plant-based leather is
capable of it's a phenomenal material
everybody loves their leather whether
it's for their clothes or their car cto
david breslauer is approaching the issue
from a scientist's perspective he says
leather is a huge industry to take on
but the fashion world has always
embraced innovation especially the kind
that helps fight climate change
the fewer cows we grow industrially
the less of the less emissions we're
going to have so there's a huge impact
to climate change and for almost all
major fashion brands
their biggest contributor to greenhouse
gas emissions are from the from the cows
that make their leather and then there's
deforestation there's deforestation
biodiversity loss ecological collapse
the list goes on and on but in order for
consumers to adopt mushroom leather it
needs to be durable workable and most
importantly look and feel like the real
thing
so we're getting really really close
with this material to
having something completely looking like
leather
beatrice ambellard is a leather artisan
with four decades of experience and says
this keeps with the trend of finding
plant-based alternatives to what we eat
and where i believe people are ready for
changes they're ready for innovation
for me combining all techniques with
biomaterials
is an incredible opportunity
what's that like for you this is amazing
it's an incredible feeling it's
combining the two she works with michael
works another bay area company that's
got the fashion industry doing double
takes
i see this material working everywhere
where leather goes sophia wang and her
co-founder phil ross have been pushing
the boundaries of leather since 2003
their proprietary reishi leather appears
close to the real thing what kind of
testing are you guys doing to make sure
that it is durable
we do do accelerated wear testing
exposing reishi to the elements just to
demonstrate that this material
is competitive to leather in terms of
durability and strength and resistance
their product finds purpose from
potentially life-saving sheets
interwoven with bulletproof kevlar to
incorporating conductive wiring in the
fibers allowing for smart fashion that
connects to your devices and even
leather enmeshed with gold thread for
well you know one of those hundred
thousand dollar designer bags they need
to justify
redefining luxury we work with our
partners to actually grow our materials
to those customized needs which is not
something you can do with any other
natural material she says that if you
can think of a luxury brand they've
probably worked with them like hermes
the high priest of french leather
products the company worked with the
storied brand on an iconic bag in 2021.
it all points to a future where
guilt-free fashion could be the norm and
instead of traditional leather on our
back or in our hand we'll be making room
for mushrooms
for cbs mornings lilia luciano berkeley
california
i like the way they're thinking i'm all
for it uh yeah it's very cool and if
your plane goes down in a remote
location you know you could always eat
your leather shoe
is that where your mind went i just
you know i eat a lot of mushrooms a
little rosemary olive oil 40 minutes in
the oven 400 degrees but it doesn't have
a bad smell no it doesn't if you can do
this and not hurt animals if this saves
the animals it is worth it and if you
lose a bet you can eat your shoe
what's happening we'll be right back i
don't know what it's a lot of bad bets i
don't know they're eating shoes and
mushrooms
we'll see in a bit